a local nurse is under investigation
accused of sexually assaulting a patient
while she slept it's news our i-team
first broke on 8newsnow.com and along
with inside of our app david charns was
the only reporter in court and david
police say they're looking into whether
this might have happened before denise
metro detectives say 31 year old ricardo
medeiros a registered nurse may have
more victims and in court a judge said
mederos is under investigation for at
least one other similar allegation this
is what we've learned so far a 54 year
old woman telling the eye team she's
battling cancer
and woke up to mederos on top of her at
sunrise hospital and medical center she
says this happened several days ago and
she says she was sedated at the time
waking up to the incident now in court
the prosecutor described that woman as
quote random and vulnerable mederos is
licensed with the nevada state board of
nursing and records show he has no prior
disciplinary action against him the
judge saying mederos is under
investigation for
a supposed similar incident from 2019
though it is unclear if that too
happened at sunrise now in a statement a
hospital spokesman tells us quote when
made aware of the alleged incident we
immediately notified law enforcement and
we are assisting with their
investigation he goes on to say as a
community dedicated to healing we are
heartbroken that something like this
could happen the victim also telling the
i-team she is returning to the hospital
tomorrow for testing
and an exam
the judge setting the bail at three
thousand dollars in this case saying
moderos cannot practice as a nurse while
this case now moves forward we are
expecting some more information in the
days to come and we'll of course bring
you that here on the news at six o'clock
i'm david charns eight news now